you want to believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can ace the
interview and get the job the key to a
successful interview out of the gate is
listen when you're being spoken to don't
ever cut off the interviewer who often
and always will start the conversation
by saying good morning good afternoon
I'm glad you came in I've got your
resume in front of me don't cut them off
listen to the question when they're
finished then answer never look overly
anxious because you should be confident
about your prospects you should make the
assumption we are going to the interview
you're gonna get the job that's what I
tell everybody including my kids when
you get the opportunity to get an
interview assume you're good enough and
the only reason they've asked you to
come in is they're assuming they want to
hire you go in with that impression of
yourself not overly confident look I
know you want me and I want to work for
you let's talk about that that's the
best way to do it if you are if you see
nervous or weak and again I stress this
I can't stress it enough look at them in
the eyes never ever look away when being
asked the question or being asked
anything you've got to make that
connection people remember that more
than anything else
number one is conduct research prior to
going to the interview now I'm not
talking about knowing what the company
does you probably did that prior to
actually applying I'm talking getting
granular get more into it dive into
Google dive into their website figure
out this company so that when you go in
you're ready to talk shop and if you
know who you're actually going to be
interviewing with in terms of like the
person's name do research on them which
is tip number two all right you're not
always going to know but a lot of times
they're gonna tell you you're gonna be
meeting with X he is or she is whatever
alright do research on them LinkedIn is
a beautiful thing and it's an amazing
resource to get a lot of info on a lot
of people have the information in the
back of your head alright and if you can
use any of it in the general flow of
conversation do it but don't go in there
man like so your husband
Rick looks fantastic after the nose job
and Jack and Jamie are two boys my god
you will look like a super stalker and
this is counterproductive to actually
getting a job you're not going in to do
an interview you're going in to sell
yourself you're going in to present
yourself as a valuable extraordinary
product that no matter what they offer
you in money you're worth a hundred
times that this is all about selling
okay you want a job this is about
selling yourself now I'm gonna tell you
right now when I go into an interview to
get a job I don't come out without it
close they'll either hire me on the spot
or they'll regret not hiring me you
might not hire me but I promise you you
will regret not hiring me and are you'll
say dude who was that cat who was that
guy that just came in here you want to
control that interview and make it a
sales presentation
tell him you're extraordinary tell them
you're great tell him you can make a
difference can oversell yourself if you
have to don't undersell yourself over
commit over commit over a promise sell
if you don't know how to sell get my
book seller be sold the book is sick
fundamentals of how to sell anything
yourself a product a brand to market
yourself to correctly promote yourself
because here's the truth if you're
worried about over selling yourself the
problem is you're not sold on you so the
first thing we have to do before you go
to this interview where you're gonna
sell yourself is we're gonna get you
sold on you what makes you different
what makes you unique what makes you
extraordinary what makes you worth more
than the highest amount of money they
could ever offer you this is an
opportunity right now you're out of work
this is an opportunity to get finally to
finally get the job you want to get this
is a fresh new start you need to go in
there and bang this thing knock this
thing out of the park by selling
yourself not just doing an interview
good luck you want to make sure that you
arrive on time I generally say arrive 30
minutes in the vicinity but about ten
fifteen minutes to announce yourself in
the reception area then once you meet
your interviewer first impressions
matter and studies say it takes about
seven seconds on a prospective employer
is immediately sizing you up he or she
is deciding do they like you are you
intelligent are you kind okay you want
to have good eye contact you want to
have a nice strong handshake and you
basically want to be positive confident
and upbeat so watch your energy level
you want to be authentic and genuine but
most people need to turn up the volume
slightly first of all you should always
extend your hand
you should always offer a handshake when
you're meeting somebody new in the
interview process the key is to look
them in the eye
when you're doing it have eye contact
don't break away okay look at them and
have a firm handshake cold and clammy
hands are often the size of just being
nervous and people understand that
because they're shaking a lot of hands
but it's the eye contact
connecting visually with the eyes is
everything and believe me I've done this
a thousand times if someone looks down
when I'm shaking their hand they won't
look me in the eye
big negative if I if the interviewer
hasn't brought up the word salary should
you not right away
in the initial conversation you want to
get to know whether or not this job even
is a good fit and I always tell people
become the super start of this person
first and then you're in a much better
place to negotiate salary and though
they may even pay more for you because
of like well we can't let Denise go
she's such a fabulous candidate we were
only going to pay this much but now that
we found Inez we're willing to do more
health care flex time vacation time
these are issues you should bring up
during a first interview or you do you
wait for come back and meet mr. Smith
right come wait wait for the comeback
because again first interview should be
about is this a company I can picture
myself in and vice-versa for the
interviewer and if it is a place you can
see yourself in do though do you know
really be your best self and really let
them know why you'd be a fantastic fit
the sad you're gonna get a job you
understand what I'm saying
look you are gonna get a job I don't
care what the job markets like because
you're not out of work what do I mean
you're unemployed what's your new job
nobody goes without a
your new job is to get a job I want you
now to put more energy more effort okay
more tenacity more persistence and more
creativity into this new job getting a
new job then you gave to your last job
if you worked eight hours a day at your
last job I want you to work ten hours a
day at your new job what's your new job
your new job is to get a job look if
you're going to work for the man okay
and now you can't work for the man
because he let you go cuz his firm
failed or he got too small or your
industry collapsed in a one your fault
had nothing to do with you maybe right
or maybe it was it doesn't matter
anymore your new job is that you work
for you your new job is to go into the
marketplace and get a job so if you used
to go to work at 8 o'clock in the
morning look I need you to get up at 6 I
need you to be at work at 7 if you used
to stay till 5:00 for the man then once
you stay till 6 or 7 4 you get a job you
get it get a job is your new job you're
not out of work
I remember man tell me this I was out of
work I've been like 2 months without
work and he's like did you eat how to
work your new job is to get a job I was
like what was that thinking I literally
went unconscious for 60 days your new
job is to get a job I want you to put
more energy more effort more tenacity
more follow-through and more creativity
and even invest more money today into
your new job than you did in your old
job I would recommend that you practice
at the very least lock yourself in a
room with a mirror and practice
responses to commonly asked questions
you don't want to script it you're not
an actress you want it to be
conversational but you want to hear
yourself say these responses out loud
and if possible I would recommend that
you set up a mock interview with a
professional career counselor interview
the company as well as you being
interviewed by the company you need to
also be interviewing the company
employers appreciate someone who asks a
lot of questions again this also helps
to put you on an equal footing because
after all if things work out and you get
the job you could be dealing with this
company and these people and their work
ethics and their priorities for a long
a long time so you need to be very
comfortable with them interview the
company as much as they're interviewing
you and here's the final key and it's so
simple it's unbelievable you immediately
after the interview no matter what
happens go home and write a thank-you
letter just go home and say thank you
very much for taking the time to
interview me today I very much enjoyed
meeting you and I really hope that
something good comes up out of our talk
together and I wish you a wonderful day
write it by hand not an email get a card
from Hallmark if you like write it by
hand address it by hand put a stamp on
it
and mail it off here's an incredible
discovery I read this 25 years ago and I
read it last week is that many people
interview for the job and you know what
the company does they hire the first
person who writes a thank-you letter
because they know that write in a
thank-you letter is an indication of
character it's an indication of courtesy
it's an indication of attitude so be
sure at the end of the interview which
you have now aged be cuz you did your
research write a thank-you letter and
wait for the phone to ring thank you
guys for watching I hope you enjoyed my
quick take on this is I think people who
are going for job interviews don't
express themselves enough they're too
boring they're too much the Photoshop
version of themselves they don't you
know part of this is being part of it
you being interviewed but it's also you
interviewing them because if you can
bring more of yourself to the interview
if you can let your true spirit shine
then they might love that but they might
hate that too and I think too many
people play it safe I think too many
people don't really express who they are
and as a result you might get hired for
that reason but you won't enjoy the
culture you want to enjoy that boss
because once you start working to get
there and then you start expressing
yourself you realize that it's not a
great fit and so I wouldn't be so
concerned always about getting the job I
think too many people are too attached
to landing that perfect job but then
when you get in there you know it's not
the right fit for you people want the AC
interview right it's that goal I got
this great job opportunity and you
really want to do well in it but
may not be the perfect job for you and I
would just encourage you to really think
about interviewing them just as much as
they're interviewing you and by showing
yourself and being creative and being
honest and being vulnerable I want I
want them to either love me or hate me
and I'm okay with getting a no because
the people who love me will want to
bring me in the worst thing that I want
to be is just have someone to be on the
fence about me
I think if you could bring that to a job
interview and extend that to when you're
selling the clients or talking to the
media or talking investors if you're
just vanilla and boring then people
won't care where if you have people love
you or hate you
then you'll end up working with the
people that you want to work with so
thank you so much for watching I'd love
to know which of the clips meant the
most to you as well as what your take is
on getting the job interview and how to
perform what your advice what your tips
are leaving the comments below I'm going
to join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon